carote carote solo carote bene tutti
ragazzi pervenute quest'anno vini che
sono su fa vj e oggi siamo imposti
volgiamo prima di quello di oggi vediamo
se ho perso il mio smalto
no ragazzi ed esteriore veramente carino
come non mai giocata niente di simile
cioè di simile sono lì in fossi col però
ti rendi conto che non si può fare in
vaticano impossibile per questo cioè non
si può fare non ci può arrivare a una
distanza troppo siderale capito non puoi
arrivare lì a meno che non ti spingi ma
non c'è modo a meno che non fai saltare
le bombe prima in qualche modo ma non so
come mai iniziano a ragazzi ci devo
riuscire a farmi tutti è veramente
difficile ma ci devo riuscire
ti prego pam perfetto lasciati parco
dell'oglio porca pensava la prendesse lo
stesso la moneta che cosa ci fa lì noi
uno shock a ragazzi io non mi muovo di
qui c'è stato già un video dove in un
episodio ho fatto un livello e non l'ho
finito proverò a vedere se pur in questa
attenzione
questo era buono la tattica l'ho trovata
ragazzi dalla strada nativo devo
sbattere sul bordo del luogo e poi e poi
darmi la propulsione dopo scommetto che
così riesco però è molto difficile
bellissimo
ragazzi ragazzi ragazzi è stato
incredibile fermi tutti
guarda guarda maestri alla maestria la
maestria fa la manina la manina ma in
noi donna come setta mcqueen che vinceva
con la lingua uguale o ci aveva messo in
bocca per primo livello ma ne è valsa la
pena veramente fighissimo nessuno lavora
mai finito tranne secondo botto run due
sedi end la fine demo day che a sto
guidando un po la madonna ci devo
colpire qualcuno compie così li ci sono
degli stop mi dicono ritornare indietro
cosa che io non farò scusa nonno scusa
nonno quanti non ne esistono
spiegami che razza di mappa open
problema chi l'ha fatta bene il resto un
po meno prove otterranno più secret
stand si un bravo che ami amati subito
giù che tanto vi serve andiamo avanti
ragazzi motorrad
a me non mi danno sfida perché sono
troppo forte
[Musica]
perché sono troppo forte l'ho detto
prima
basta crea una zucca che facciamo
livello di halloween va bene dai siamo a
tema halloween creiamo una zucca forza
zuccalà facciamo innanzitutto anno
quanti come ci sono i rom ad onna
facciamo una zucca grigia brevetta
proprio perché l'ora di creare una zucca
gli occhi della gioia la madonna che
ansia questi che ansia se non avesse
loro corribile il naso il naso lo
facciamo così anno senza naso non
facevano con triangolo dai nomi almeno
un caso classico control mentre caso
sono schiatto ok stemme non so cosa
siano al gambo il gambo della zucca
quindi il gambo lo facciamo così quello
che sembra tipo su dovuto è un pokémon
la bocca la metti cos'è una mazza da
golf quella come bocca questa roba
madonna e io direi che tra tutte
metterei questa qua che mi sembra la più
krypi che è il suo ditino bruttissimo
dovrebbe avercela fatta attenzione gli
accessori
cos'è sta roba no accessori non ho
capito cosa dovrebbero essere sti cosi
famiglie del risultato finance è
veramente la cosa più inquietante della
mia vita
frankenstein zucca
bel numero epic block mason rocca che
figo e devo farlo diventare tutto di un
colore giusto di colore bianco di colore
grigio humour stakeholder square
d'arques dark grey to win
quindi tutti scuri ok io non sono mai
stato bravo con i puzzle perché sapete
ci vuole il cervello non lo vendono su
amazon quello trovo sempre difficoltà
non è colpa mia
porco demonio porco no è il contrario
dovevo fare vaffan
e quanto difficile aiuto cosa devo fare
e basta
quanto sta durando sto gioco che
fastidio madonna raga o no rai è
veramente incredibile mi sta durando una
vita guarda rimane sempre coso madonna
riverenti impossibile come diavolo si
basa su studiata proprio porca vacca ma
solo per persone intelligenti questo
basta basta credere in me e basta
anche mia mamma quando andavo a scuola
che vedeva in me mamma faccio schifo
basta dunque 150 ottimo 150 secondi in
ferro risolvere un enigma l'ha fatto il
mio cane se nigma four seasons quattro
stagioni spero sia una pizza non è una
pizza sono morti gli altri scaffale
buste proprio lui e non avevo detto che
non lo sostituì ragazzi non gli ho mai
neanche dato un nome tra la mente li uso
poco incredibile
angelo e carla chiamiamoli così york a
vacca e va bene ragazzi buono buono
buono quando volevo numero perfetto
angelo è morto carla
parlava finché la carla va lasciala
andare non è morto anche lepri faccia ma
allora qua ok
mamma mia veramente un livello difficile
e complicato però niente che io non
possa fare ragazzi giocatore più di
tutta la mia vita
allora spetta che ci devo fare un giro
fatto bene arco demonio ha fatto bene
perfetto un altro un altro che qua è un
casino mi ricordo prima e colori
perfetto mamma mia che faresti giri
della morte sempre un casino ragazzi
adesso
aiuto mi scusi non volevo porca vacca
[Musica]
come il nokia 33 10 crossword troviamo
ragazzi facciamo lo smart rho anche oggi
prevediamo di fare un volto quello si è
fatto mia mamma è già morto ma già sta
dando però non lo colpiscono maledizione
o colpito volo sopra cali sugli altri
vabbé fa niente è da ieri un po di
precisione
bravissimo bravissimo di colpirla la
gente devi colpirla in faccia prendi
prendi la gente la gente bravo tu hai
ruolo bravissimo ora mi disse fare la
stessa cosa con questo davanti
bravissimo anche lui con i dietro
bravissimo ragazzi non è che tutto luke
però penso che non sia necessario
teoricamente nessuna altra no perché no
ancora una hd retoricamente acli kirti
uil fpl
era morto quindi ho vinto a prescindere
però lancio degli oggetti in che senso
ha proprio gli oggetti in generale va
bene ac rompo le teche bellissimo allora
open win la prima vediamo a wind non è
quella che volo colpire è cascato un
cubo di rubik
va bene con l'ananas dovrei colpire arco
demonio che non era facile già lo sapevo
però riproviamoci ridammi cosi benissimo
allora via col ketchup
ho sbagliato è difficilissimo edizione
devo colpire o per win
i rossi non vanno colpiti non colpire
rho è difficilissimo colpisci il tuo
simile che stalin no porca vacca o
chiocchio mamma mia che culo dato nel
verde la batteria del telefono ma perché
non c entra neanche dalla vittoria
questo è impossibile ma non c'entrava
comunque porca vacca
meno male che roteano giu non si sa con
che fisica è impossibile attenzione le
loro più due più due fa meno male per
male cubo di rubik
dall'altra parte di ti prego o dai
oddio è stata mamma mia era una
questione di vita o di morte ragazzi
sono state un sacco ma ho dovuto
provarci veramente difficile bromfield
text non è il primo che faccio era da un
po che non ne faceva uno presidente
tutto il livello dei rocking invece
delle cose c'è scritto che cosa sono le
cose questa una rom per esempio deve
aggrappare e ti dice cosa ci sono gli
ostacoli tipo quello è il pavimento
bellissimo è veramente un ottimo è
un'ottimo non so chi l'ha avuto per
prima con idea però l'avevo già fatta
una roba del genere è veramente figo è
strano non c'era nel nella gara dei
rokes in dieci minuti ragazzi per questo
sarebbe stato un gran livello
l'hotel in platform finis anche il
felice la testa va bene manca cosa che
mancano fatto tutti purtroppo manca un
buon trovo teoricamente che non vedo se
riuscissi a concludere colpo altro
sarebbe lo spy phone anche all'imposta
allora iniziamo con imposti col ok di
pam e vite quello ciò sia tolto perché
quello è proprio meraviglioso skypephone
l'attenzione è anche questo ce lo siamo
tolto perfetto andiamo solo su boltro
per finire ho vinto davvero non avrei
mai detto abbiamo sul buon trovo e
finiamo teoricamente che ti ho fatto
tutto incredibile tutto in una botta
sola oltre lo semplice a devo aprire la
vittoria che sta a me per semplice una
sega in realtà i ragazzi non è semplice
e mi sta mettendo però sicuro che non è
sempre che culo porca vacca non è
semplice ragazzi bene mi ha mentito o vi
giuro non è vero ma da questi successo
fortuna
perché ricordate che l'anas è perfetta
su qualsiasi cosa tranne sulla pizza
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto questo
era a prostitute io ho fatto un sacco di
livelli mi sono soffermato un botto su
alcuni veli ma io fini di tutti molto
orgoglioso di me stesso e dell'uomo che
sono oggi
iscriviti al canale e schiacciate il
tasto mi piace schiaccia della campa di
vita prima gara salvatici noi video che
escono e noi come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo video dei ragazzi
[Musica]